en irak les états unis se préparent aux
cérémonies commémorant les attentats du
11 septembre il s'agira d' honorer la
mémoire des victimes mais cette année
avec une certaine discrétion à new york
déjà
ground zero est devenue un lieu de
pèlerinage et tous et spécialement en ce
début du mois de septembre
reportage pascal golomer tristan le braz
l'embarcadère vers la statue de la
liberté
cela a toujours été et c'est encore
aujourd'hui l'un des sites les plus
fréquentés de new york
et c'est ici à quelques centaines de
mètres de ground zero que s'élève au
milieu des inévitables marchands de
souvenirs
le seul monument à ce jour à la mémoire
de toutes les victimes tuées dans
l'attentât du 11 septembre
en fait une sculpture sauvées des ruines
du world trade center un lieu de
recueillement devenu un haut lieu
touristique sans que les new-yorkais ne
soient choqués qui est arrivé est
tragique mais ça fait partie de
l'histoire et c'est pour ça que ça
attire tous ces gens il ya un avant et
un après en septembre
et c'est comme cela que les choses
désormais
quelques minutes d'horreur en effet et
tout amérique bascule dans la guerre
contre le terrorisme dans la psychose
sécuritaire et grande 0 devient un
symbole pour le monde entier
deux ans plus tard le même ground zero
est devenue un immense chantier de
construction d'une nouvelle gare
ferroviaire des immeubles de bureaux un
grand parc dix ans de travaux en
perspective
et si l'on trouve sur les étals
alentours les réminiscences du passé
destiné aux touristes
l'heure est venue pour les new yorkais
de tourner la page
elles font sortir de cette morosité
aller de l'avant garde sur c'était trop
tôt l'année dernière mais désormais nous
devons nous tourner vers l'avenir
la cérémonie qui se tiendra ici à new
york jeudi prochain sera en tout cas
très sobre pas de grands discours mais
un long moment de recueillement le temps
que les noms des deux 1792 victime soit
égrainé un à un en présence des seuls
famille